welcome everyone to our last uh day of
pi data in this new session my name is
jana meneses i'll be your host for today
and i'm super happy to be here now i'm
introducing our speaker sara sara
sari is going to speak about the
computer vision in xei explaining a
single prediction with visualization and
examples
so the connection is yours
thank you
the topic of this talk
is computer vision and explainable ai
and in this talk i will be focusing on
explaining single predictions with
visualizations and examples
sorry
the outline of this talk is that first i
will give introduction to explainable ai
and then i will focus on visual
explanations first by explaining model
agnostic climate shock
and and after that i will focus on model
specific gradient based methods
then i carry on
two explanations with similar examples
and then at the end i will conclude
the results of this talk
about terms sometimes this topic is
divided into three different categories
that aim to explain interpret and
understand ai
but in this talk
all of these are referred as explainable
a i or x ai
few words about myself so my name is
sarah tatinan
i have a research background so i have a
phd from theoretical particle physics
previously i worked as a nursing
learning developer focusing on computer
vision and deep learning
and then in my previous workplace i
worked in an explainable ai project
where my role was to be an xai
researcher
nowadays i'm a senior data scientist who
enjoys playing with explainable ai deep
learning and images
okay so let's go to the topic of this
talk so explainable ai
first i give a brief introduction to
deep learning
so let's assume we have a very simple
case where we would like to
label images
and in order to label automatically
label images we need a large image set
where each image has some
class label
then we also need a model that can take
these
images as inputs and then
it will output
the class labels
uh these models are very complex they
have millions of tunable parameters and
these parameters are organized in layers
that are connected with weights
and then this training phase can be
considered as fitting data into a very
complex model
and once we have a trend our model we
want to test our model
so we give the model some example of our
run
and then the model output uh the
prediction
the problem is here that the model is
very complex so humans
cannot understand what goes on inside of
the model so what we can see is that an
image goes in and the prediction comes
out but we don't understand at all that
why
and for this reason explainability is
needed because we would like to
understand why the result is what it is
but as nowadays we want more and more
accurate results
we need to use more and more complex
models
and the more complex our model is
the harder it is to explain it
so what we gain in accuracy we actually
lose in explainability
but explainability is very important
topic because
it links directly into database
if we don't understand how our models
are working how do we know that they are
fair
there has been examples where
ai models have not been fair
for example amazon career service that
recommended mostly males
then there has been a healthcare
algorithm that prioritized white people
and then there has been models that were
accidentally trained with offensive
images and labels which also
inherited
the model
outputs
so
understanding the model is very
essential
so explanation methods are needed
and what these explanations
could mean
is that on top of the prediction we
would get some kind of additional
information
on the prediction
for example the breadth course the
prediction scores
or
some statistics correlations or graphs
that could explain better why the
prediction is what it is
then there is also possibility of
visualizing the areas of attention so
which pixels were the most important
for the predicted class
and then there are explanations by
similar examples and in this talk i will
focus on the number two and three
it's important to notice
that explainable ai is a broad topic
and in this talk i will only focus on
small part of it
so explainable a iai can be roughly
divided into the three categories
the first one is pre-model
explainability which aims to understand
the training data
then the second type
is a local post model explainability so
understanding one sample
and then the third category is a
global post-model explainability that
aims to understand the model's overall
behavior
if you want to apply explainable
explainable ai to your models it's often
best to use as diverse set of
explainability methods as possible
the idea behind alignment shop
is
that
the starting point is that we would like
to understand why the model
predicted the class a
and in order to do this lemon shop take
this input image and then it starts to
make changes to this input image
so it always makes a small modification
then it gives this modified image to the
model
and see how the predictions change
then they represent this process over
and over again until they have enough
data
to draw conclusions
and lime and shop
works a bit differently how they draw
the conclusions so lime is a lighter
approximation to explain the results
where a sharp is a heavier computation
but it has strong metabolical
foundation in game theory
but these both models aim
to highlight those pixels that were the
most
important for the predicted class a
good the strength of learn and shop is
that they are independent of the model
we don't need to know anything about the
model we just need to be able to always
make new predictions using the model
lemon shop are also very white very
widely used so there are ready-made
packages for this
but with images
they are problematic because they are
very slow
it requires multiple predictions so
multiple passes through the complex
network
then
also the results with images are not
always very convincing
and you show what this means is that i
did some tests with a shop
so i gave shop one image of my own and
then i
wanted to compute the explanations for
the top
five categories the module predicted
i
calculated from 2000 evaluations to 10
000 evaluations which took from 5
minutes to 24 minutes
to compute and what i noticed was that
this method is very time consuming and
actually the explanations are not
looking very promising
so for example looking at these 10 000
evaluation
this explanation doesn't really help me
to understand any better what goes on in
uh the model
so alignment shop are generally not
recommended to use uh with images as the
results are not the best possible they
work with different type of problems
very well but images are challenging
but if you want to have these visual
explanations and alignment shop are not
the best possible what should you use
so let's next focus on gradient-based
methods that are model specific
the idea behind gradient-based methods
is
that first
we do one forward pass through the
network to get the prediction
this is the step we always do when we
want to have a prediction
then from the output layer we select one
class
and we reverse engineer
the calculations from the output layer
back to the input layer to see which
pixels contributed to most to the given
desired prediction
it's important to note this
sorry
no
it's important to notice that there are
many different versions of how to do
this reverse engineering so
gradient-based methods is not just one
method but it's a group of methods
but what is common to all of them is
that they are very fast with images and
deep learning
as we only need one forward and one back
for backward pass through the network
the problem with these methods are that
they are model specific
so we need to understand
exactly what the model architecture is
in order to reverse engineer
the calculations
to show some examples what these
explanations could look like
here is an example of one of the first
papers
around this topic
and in this image there's a
church tractor and mandatory
and their explanations and what we can
see that these explanations
clearly seem to be promising as they
highlight the correct pixels
but these uh gradient-based methods are
a bit problematic because they are not
very class specific
so if we have an image where there is a
dog and a cat and we would like to
understand why the model predicted the
cat's image and why it predicted that
there is a dog in the image the
explanations look very similar
for this reason
sorry this is
okay
for this reason cam
was
invented
so uh
the idea behind uh credcam is that it
aims to improve the death class
discrimination because it only takes a
certain type of gradients into a couch
and now if you ask that why did the
model predicted uh the class cat and why
did the predict the class dog we can
clearly see that these explanations
highlight the cat pixels and the dot
pixels so the explanations seem to be
working very well
but these uh not being class specific is
not the only problem that these gradient
based methods
are facing
there was one research group that
focused on looking into these
explanation techniques
and in their paper they first made the
hypothesis
that if the model learned the concept of
the bird
explanations should highlight the pixels
of the bird too
and the outcome was that yes
that's correct and they do that but it
looks a lot these explanations look a
lot like an edge detector and not really
a model explanation
edge detector is a mathematical trick
that simply compares neighboring pixels
to get to detect edges in the image and
it doesn't need any model or training
data
based on this result
they decided to do another hypothesis
that if trend waves are replaced with
random numbers explanations should not
highlight the bird
and what they noticed was that when they
started replacing the drain weights with
random numbers they noticed that the
results didn't change once
so even though the model was completely
random the explanation still highlighted
the bird
in the image
so after making multiple
tests with this explainability uh with
these explainability techniques they
noticed that actually some of these
widely deployed saliency methods are
independent of both the data the model
was trained on and the model parameters
but
what they noticed in this paper was that
actually
this method called credcam performs
really well and it seems to be loyal to
the model
for these reasons i decided uh to play
around uh with grad cam myself
and what i noticed was that the
explanations of the correct class looks
very good so here is the explanations of
the class tabby gets and it clearly
highlights the face of the cats
but what i noticed was that the
incorrect classes highlight the same
pixels too
so
uh
if the correct and incorrect classes
highlight the same pixels
does this actually help me to understand
any better what my model is doing
and this uh leads into a question that
are these pixel based explanations
actually any good
when i'm using these pixel based
explanations it's very hard to often
see that
is the models bad because my model is
working badly or
am i using the wrong explanation
technique
or uh are these both a problem
but it's good to know this that uh this
is still kind of young research uh topic
so there is a lot of ongoing research to
improve these methods
so perhaps in the future
these explanations are more helpful
okay
let's then uh
proceed into explanations with similar
examples here
i will use again
the same image i used previously i give
this image to a model and the model
outputs the predictions
but when you look into the predictions
and for example search some
stereotypical images of these classes
sorry
it's clear to be a bit confused because
it's very hard to understand that why
did the model
predict that this image of a cuts
belongs into these classes
so the question is that
how could we understand better the
predicted labels so why did the model
think that this image of a cats belonged
in these categories that doesn't seem to
do anything with the cats
and what i did or what you can do is to
go through your training data to
discover hints
there is a
internet web page
called know your data where you can
browse through different classes
categories that are used to train these
models
and for this i selected three these
three cases and went through the
training data
and what i noticed
uh is that uh there's a lot of cats in
different categories
so it's no wonder that the image thinks
that um that the model thinks that the
image belongs into these classes because
these cats are everywhere in these
classes
but going through the training data
yourself by hand
is very time consuming and laborers
so you would like
so the question is
that could you do this
automatically
and find the closest images
and the answer is actually yes we can
find the closest images by using image
embeddings
so what is an image embedding
image this embeddings vector can be
calculated from one layer before the
output layer and similar images should
have similar embeddings
when i was googling around to find some
technique how to find similar images i
came across this blog post from towards
dead science that described
the process of how to compute the image
embeddings
this blog post didn't use image
embeddings for explanation purposes
uh it was more generally that if we have
some example image how can we find the
most similar images
but in this blog post there was a link
to the github
where one can find the code that was
used to produce these results so i
decided to take the code
and then i cleaned it up a bit and
noticed that actually it's very easy
to compute these embeddings we only need
a few lines of code
what we need uh is uh the model so if
you have a model of your own you can use
that one so load that one um into your
code
or
if you haven't yet trained any model you
can also try to use these general role
models that are trained with imagenet
images
the length of the embedding vector
depends a bit on which model
architecture you are using so i was to
compute
the similar images in this talk i used
the same network that the original blog
post was using so
efficientnetb0
and with that the embedding vector
length is 1280.
what else do we need is that we need
some image bank
so preferably the training data
and then we need one example image
and what we do is that uh we compute
these embedding vectors to all of the
images in the image func and then
compute the embedding vectors in our
example image then we compare these
embedding vectors
and we find the closest embedding
vectors to our example
and then we simply
output the results
so here i was using an image set of cuts
and here is the result uh that with this
image embeddings i managed to get so as
you can see
these example images are very close
similar they are similar black and white
cuts as my example image is
but if i would like to use
this explanation technique uh to explain
the models uh these general image net
models
i ran into a problem because for this i
would need to have a training i would
need to have the trainings that uh that
the models were trained on
but these image net images are not
actually publicly available
so i can't give a full explanation on
why the general
models
predicted what they predicted
but in this talk uh i will be using
three uh different tensorflow data sets
so i going to be using the stanford docs
doc versus cats and then surfalo flowers
datasets
and how we can use this to explain our
model protection
is
that in here i'll be using the stand for
dogs
datasets which has different breeds of
dogs
i need an example image of a dog
i will be using my sister's dog as an
example i give this image to a model and
the model predicts that it's for inspect
very
high
prediction score
then i use these similar examples to
find
explanations that are perhaps why
the model predicted the friends bulldog
and as you can see the french bulldog
category has very similar
images than what our example image has
but we can use also this as kind of as a
what-if tool
so what if it's not reference product
what kind of results we would get
and here
we can clearly see that uh boston bull
is very close to our example image
so uh it's it's very similar shape but
the color of bostonville is different
so based on this uh example image um i
think we can be quite sure that the
actual uh prediction was correct and
this uh image belongs in the french
bulldog category
so these image embeddings are very nice
to use to explain the model predictions
but it's a very neat technique to use
elsewhere as well
with these image embeddings we can
actually detect data leakages
so when we are training a model we
typically split the data into training
and test sets
then we use this training set to train
our model and after the model is trained
we want to evaluate the model
performance using these test sets
some very promising looking results so
the test set accuracies are very high
but when we tried this model with real
life examples we noticed that the models
are not actually very good
and one possible thing that might cause
this is that when we were testing the
model
data leakage happened
and data leakage
is when the test set data is used during
the training process
and this will lead into overly
optimistic estimate of the more model
performance because the unseen data we
use to test the model is actually images
that the model has already seen
data leakage is often very difficult to
find
but we can actually use this embeddings
technique to check if the train set has
very similar images than the test sets
so
um
yep sorry we have i just two minutes
finished yeah okay i'm almost done yeah
yeah so uh this tends to flow
at it
i
split it randomly in the tests and
training sets and i notice that with
this data set it's very likely that dead
leakage will happen because there are
many duplicates of the same image
that has
okay so as a conclusion i first went
through the shop
which can be summarized being modular
agnostic and it's based on game theory
but it's not very good with images and
then i went through the gradient test
models which is fast
but it's not very class specific or
loyal to the world at all and then there
was crackdown which is fast it improves
class discrimination
and it's loyal to the model but it's not
very nations by examples and as a bonus
it can be also find the data leakages in
the training
data
okay thank you and thanks to my home
colleagues as well please if there is
anything you'd like to ask there's
perhaps one minute
sorry um thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
and we have
one minute maybe we can ask this
question and answer this question
willian is asking do you think that
google image used embeddings to show
related images after a query has been
done in the results
yes that's very likely that what can
happen also i believe that in iphones
where there is that find the similar
images and then there is different
people it might use the same tactic that
image embeddings are used to find the
similar uh or the
closest uh humans that can be shown
in the show
yeah
okay thank you very much sarah thank you
for the next question the nice talk
thank you
you